speaking of people who are suffering
serious delusions Rachel Maddow worries
Trump will probably will be probably
president for life if he wins in 2024.
MSNBC host notes and the current
political movement far-right politics is
coinciding with far-right violence it's
a lie they just have to say it I I have
to wonder
you know there are a lot of evil people
out there like you know what's going on
in uh how do you pronounce it xinjiang
xinjiang and uh with the with the uyghur
Muslim camps yeah that's evil stuff
right the forced abortions like
nightmarishly evil Rachel Maddow is a
kind of evil you know but I wouldn't put
her anywhere near like genocide level
but pretty evil in that she goes on her
show and says things that any sane
person even a liberal electus would know
is just crackpot psychotic nonsense but
she says it anyway because she gets a
lot of money ratings I mean she she was
the highest rated uh uh Caster on on
MSNBC you know and so she made a lot of
money off of it she got huge ratings and
she continues to Parrot these just I
mean crazy ludicrous narratives like
yeah Donald Trump and she was one of the
biggest proponents of the whole Russia
hoax and you know and she continues to
parrot that to this day even though it's
been debunked over and over because she
has a monetary incentive absolutely
right there's no reason she started
seeing like guys I've changed my mind
not the case her ratings would probably
collapse all of the the uh attention
that her show gets would go away in some
cases the way our media works it
incentivizes people to get more and more
crazy I mean we see this YouTube is same
exactly we see an independent media all
the time the people will start saying
more outlandish things I mean let's
think of like the clip 80 thumbnails
that people put out they might need to
because it drives people to their
channel on the other hand like are they
always super accurate no
I think with Rachel Maddow what's
interesting is there is an actual
hysteria and fear Underneath It All she
really does seem to be personally
panicked about Trump's influence on the
country you don't think so absolutely if
you watch it it looks like she's just
saying to have the clip we should pull
it up let's just I'll show you a bit of
it this morning heading into what we
knew would be two big important Court
hearings on these Trump cases today in
federal court in Georgia and federal
court indeed probably what he was
planning probably what he was thinking
but
per the New York Times it does seem sort
of significant that that's what he's now
telling people
that's what he's telling people he's
gonna do he will solve his jumble of
legal problems by winning the election
and you know whatever you think about
that
that's how he's thinking about that okay
and what does that say about the
election for all of the rest of us right
it means in his own mind and those of
his campaign and his supporters
presumably these are the stakes
and again whatever you think about that
as a legal strategy for Trump that is
how he is thinking about the election
how many times was she going to say the
same thing over and over again just
there you know she said I think four
times Trump's strategy to get rid of his
legal problems is to win the election
think about that what does that what do
you think that means it does what do you
think it means no no no the point is
Rachel Maddow has no passion and is
saying literally nothing she is
pattering she is speaking words with no
meaning to extend time the thing she is
saying exist only in I gotta get through
this hour and then I'm going to have
lunch with the girls I would love to get
her off script and interview her she's
not on script she's probably just
the election means one of two things
if this is the way he's going to
approach it we should keep saying it
over and over again he loses the
election he can't go into specifics
because she doesn't actually understand
and if she brought out any actual facts
and is that for life that he gets to be
president will we keep having more
elections or no
if every election is a new opportunity
for him to go to prison do you think he
allows us to have new elections what
does that mean this is total
fear-mongering nobody believes that
there is no Avenue for Donald Trump to
possibly be able to suspend elections
what's he going to do suspend the
Constitution to to make it so that he's
president for Life nobody actually
believes that so she's clearly look in
that minute she said I think maybe like
15 different words
she explained nothing and she said over
and over and over again what you think
about what Trump thinks that means Trump
thinks this and no matter what you think
that means Trump means this which means
in the election Trump will think this
and isn't teleporters this that means
whatever you think Trump thinks this
like did she okay at all how he would do
that did she explain that at all well of
course not yeah she doesn't believe that
she can't evilness she doesn't believe
anything she's saying she's not actually
saying anything and she this is this
this is the challenge you know I think
about you got the world economic Forum
you will own nothing and you'll be happy
and you got these video clips where
parents are like my baby is you know
gonna get the the medication we're gonna
sterilize the kid and stuff like that
and I'm just like at a certain point
what do you do when you're watching
Lemmings I mean this figuratively when
you're watching them walk off a cliff
now I know Disney forced them off a
cliff with a broom yeah I'm making a
point yeah Lemmings don't actually walk
off cliffs like that yeah the Disney
producers shoved them off with brooms
like get out of here we're gonna film it
and make money off you but it's actually
a good example of what this people are
mindlessly Marching towards their own
demise do you step in I've only been
trying you are we are the show is doing
that but not everyone's gonna listen you
just can't grab them by the throat and
and pull them back or you'll be
considered the aggressor you've got to
let them go but yeah so we're watching
we're watching them March toward the
cliff and we're going stop please please
don't do it and they're like you're so
crazy
they're going off the ratings Cliff
though I mean like hey come on who
watches MSNBC at this point I mean so
when they find out hotels and things I
saw Chuck Todd over the weekend and this
is pretty funny I was listening to Chuck
Todd and he was like the thing about
Trump's election lies are and I was like
dude election claims call them claims
don't make the assumption that they're
like it was just to purport that it was
a lie without it it was it's to make
sure that you already know to be on
guard to whatever Trump is yeah it was a
tribalist like a tribalist flag being
raised like if you're part of our group
we all know wink wink that he's it's a
lie anyway so an Acclaim might imply
that there's some credit to them which
they cannot allow right there can't be
any reason why he would be right in any
way yeah it was a neutral would have
been a neutral statement was to say talk
about his claims as opposed to uh Rachel
got 3.9 million viewers the number one
show across all of Television including
broadcast wow she's getting on Fox News
well I mean of course they beat up Fox
News they fired Tucker I mean what I
mean sure but this is right yeah no one
else but this is the point
this is it Rachel Maddow is going to say
next thing she like President Trump will
be president for Life Next thing she's
going to come out and she's going to
start she's got to increase it now she's
gonna come out and be like well Trump's
going to start rounding people up and
then she's gonna talk about trains and
then she's going to talk about whatever
it is that's going to terrify people and
convince them they have to watch glued
to it like some kind of disgusting drug
I think she doesn't realize the power
she has as an individual the people that
are afraid of Donald Trump that are
afraid of some external power don't
realize the amount of power they have
within their own Community to prevent
and buffer from that stuff yeah but I
think she wants it right like if if she
is the most popular show on television
right now and she gets to scare you and
so you come back to listen to her every
day to say Rachel what what should I
know you you're telling me all these
awful things you're really insightful
you know she knows she has influence she
knows she has power I think that's why
she can present in a monologue like this
that references nothing she repeats the
same phrase over and over again she
doesn't cite any facts she's not like
because in this law would allow him to
do whoever she's just speculating
knowing that people will be afraid of it
that's it that's all she's doing and
she's good at it meaning that she's
assuming that her audience already
believes her premise absolutely
absolutely they do I mean in my opinion
that is the reason that she is pulling
you know three point something million
viewers uh on her her episode I believe
she only does like two or three episodes
a week at this point she somehow gets
away with that because you know she does
have a lot of power no but nobody
watches any other Show on MSNBC she's
retired again yeah she checked out a
long time ago I mean come on you go to
any person how old is she someone look
apologies yeah look it up was she like
her mid late 40s I think she might even
be older than that really she's been
around for a long time born in 73 so
that would make her 50 48 currently 48.
born on April 1st happy April Fool's Day
Rachel one day before me she was born in
1973 yeah April 1st 1973. this should be
50. yes so she's 48 no so she'd be 50.
50. no 48 she'll be
what year I mean 49 yeah because your
birthday's in April okay so she'll be 15
1974. no she'd still be 50. so this
probably looks out of date she says
she's either way yeah she'd be 50. she's
up there
sorry for all the 50 plus year olds out
there that is really weird anyway she's
retired man I'm saying 48 years old on
this since she was born April 1st 1973.
it's like the table what are you looking
at let's just
GPT is going to feed us such trash for
the next two decades but what was the
argument we knew when her her birth year
was like bro she's 50. it was like turn
right now you're wrong the ocean's right
there I'm like turn right okay anyway
the point is she's retired she's 50 and
they went to her and said what are you
doing and she goes I just want to go to
sleep I'm just so tired and sad and
pathetic and they're like we'll give you
five million dollars to do a show once a
week I guess fine
that's what she's doing that's why she's
patterning on the show that's why she's
just she's she's going like Donald Trump
wants to be president that means he'll
run for president and no matter what you
think about that he's gonna tell his
supporters he's running for president so
you might not want to be president but
he's gonna run and you know what that
means he'll tell his supporters he's
running no matter what it is you think
that's literally what she did well this
place off the offer wild also she's
getting paid millions of dollars to do
this like what a sweet gig guys I don't
know what to tell you what are they
gonna do fire her I mean if MSNBC
doesn't have a network without Rachel
Maddow I mean what is there like I want
to name another uh MSNBC host to be
honest with you I mean Chris Matthews I
mean I can see it right here Chris no he
got fired actually because he said
something uh sexist or right right right
um who's Chris Hayes uh Chris Hayes is
he is he also Chris Hayes uh but Chuck
Todd he's out there right Chuck Todd's
uh NBC yeah MSNBC is Chris Hayes all
right you got one good point um I have
the feeling oh I don't know um oh Brian
Brian Williams right because he got
fired for being a lion yeah he said he
was in an Apache helicopter or whatever
being shot by sniper fire so we were all
surprised to learn that a guy on cable
TV news was lying to us and then they
fired him and then MSNBC was like he's
our guy that's right that's right sounds
great I wonder if Rachel goes home at
night and is like I hate this job I do
not want to even think about politics
but she's getting paid 15 million
dollars uh what a year or what's this
yeah probably something like just go
repeat the crap I think you're
overlooking like the social position 20
million 20 million she's getting paid 20
million dollars to barely say anything
one million dollars to go on TV
she doesn't have to memorize any hard
information I can't even believe that
she like there's no way there's a script
there but also everyone wants to invite
her to things and have her places like
there is a social currency that she
knows she has I think she wouldn't give
up this job even though she's not
passionate about it if she started a new
show that was less political I think
she'd still have a lot of followers I
think you can't really step away from
that Prestige like I think there is sort
of something to being the like the
female I don't personally agree with it
but I think she has been told you know
this you're this uh high-powered female
political commentator you have your own
show it would be harder for her to
transition to like something like Oprah
did where she just like goes around
interviewing people I think there's an
ego part to it not that she should feel
ashamed of it but what happened to
Hillary Clinton had her show did that do
well is it canceled because I think
that's a good yeah she got her own show
on a major streaming platform where
she's gonna like interview other high
profile women and stuff and they're
gonna paint and stuff what I'm wondering
is that would be a good kind of like
thing to check to see how Wild Mata
would do on her own what's up what's up
with all these left-wing people painting
nowadays I mean is it there's just so
much money in painting and George Bush
too well short well I guess George well
I mean he's not too right at this point
I don't know but you see Hunter Biden
you know he's now painting again he was
doing it before but he's now painting
again and paying fifteen thousand six
hundred dollars per month in rent but he
can't pay child support for the uh the
granddaughter that they just decided
they acknowledge yeah no they just
decided to acknowledge it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time